I mean all of these are horrible choices
I'd rather do neither of these can I
choose to do it either whatever there
have a permanent fish face when posing
for pictures or only be able to kiss
like a fish that is how I kiss it's what
I'm known for this is a sad turn of
events because I have never taken a
photograph without a fish face and I
don't know how to kiss anyway other than
I feel no he's at a standstill so this
is like real salt in the wound poor wife
your buzz feed would you rather help a
child find their parents at Disneyworld
or in a house of mirrors house of
mirrors sounds like I'm in the middle of
my recurring nightmare so I'm going to
help a child find their parents at
Disneyworld these aren't actually
happening that's gonna happen to you Oh
a house of mirrors I could do that the
Disney World
mirrors make me dizzy and I don't like
to look in mirrors anymore anyway would
you rather constantly forget your own
name or your significant others names
this is my own is coming this is you
just have to want punishment if you
choose the second one well I mean I'd
rather forget my own name right that's
the only answer who would answer the
other way I would rather forget my
significant others name and weather the
storm I have a best friend who can't
remember anything or a best friend who
always runs into walls best friend who
can't remember anything it's not so bad
to run into walls I've run into a few
walls I'm going with best friend
who always runs into balls would you
rather get attacked by a shark or eat
your character the sushi roll look I
gotta eat my character I mean it's gotta
be delicious absolutely now it is so
adorable so cute and there's so much of
her I could probably eat on her for
months
am i forced to do one um I would rather
feed us my character to a shark I don't
really eat fish so it's a kind of yeah
that that's why I had no choice and then
to make me eat my own characters fish of
all fish you know you know yeah you
really are I hope you know how horrible
you are by now
all right